for centuries we only knew of the
handful of planets in our own solar
system
now astronomers are finding thousands of
new worlds around alien stars exoplanets
we are discovering exoplanets by the
bucket
or as many planets out there as there
are stars and there are hundreds of
billions of stars in the galaxy
but out of billions of exoplanets are
there any that could offer new
opportunities for humanity to thrive and
provide sanctuary in a dangerous
universe is there an earth 2.0
[Music]
is there 2.0 out there
that will be truly amazing August 2016
astronomers announced that earth 2.0
could be closer than anyone ever
expected a planet orbiting the Suns
nearest stellar neighbor the red dwarf
Proxima Centauri so it turns out that
our nearest star neighbor has an
exoplanet it's only about 4 light years
away so that means that it's actually
potentially possible for us to get there
and to explore it scientists named the
planet after the star Proxima Centauri B
or Proxima B for short a world that
appears to be a lot like Earth
from the way it's tugging on the star
Proxima Centauri we know that it has 1.3
times the Earth's mass but it's roughly
the same size as the earth of the
exoplanets we know about most are
uninhabitable gas giants like Jupiter
Proxima B is a rare find an earth-sized
planet but an earth-sized planet might
not be earth-like a true second earth
must also be the right distance from its
star the habitable zone or some people
call it the Goldilocks region is a
distance away from the star where you're
not so close where you're gonna burn up
and evaporate all of your liquids and
you're not so far away where you're
frigid and cold so it's that special
region where it's just just right
[Music]
does Proxima B lie in this region could
it have liquid water Proxima Centauri B
or Bizet's star once every eleven point
two days so compare that to the earth
which goes around the Sun once every 365
days that's because the planet is much
much closer to the star than the earth
is to the Sun
Earth orbits 93 million miles from the
Sun Proxima be orbits 20 times closer
under five million miles from its star
you might think that próxima be should
be you know a really a fried world a
burnt-out husk if you will but próxima
bees son is very different than ours
at just over 5,000 degrees Fahrenheit
it's half as hot and roughly eight times
smaller an m-class red dwarf star an M
dwarf the approximate V is around is
much less bright much less hot so you
can orbit much closer to that star and
be at the same temperature that we are
here on earth
próxima bees tight orbit around the red
dwarf could make the planet habitable
but it would be very different from
Earth
the star dominates the sky lighting any
oceans and mountains with an alien red
glow so Proxima be maybe the earth 2.0
that we've been looking for
but in 2017 the dim red dwarf star
erupts in a way that's unlike anything
we've seen before
blasting the planets with radiation a
mega flare they're like solar flares but
they can be much more powerful in fact
they can outshine the star itself our
Sun releases powerful solar flares when
its magnetic field becomes tangled
but the Mega Flare is ten times stronger
than our sons strongest flares on an M
dwarf star that magnetic field can get a
lot more tangled than on our own Sun
that means that when a flare happens it
can release a lot more energy
scientists believe that mega flares like
this or planet-killers
radiation tears the atmosphere from the
planet
and bees mega flares that próxima be
roughly once every year
red door stars are incredibly
temperamental they are not good parents
to their planets
so if proxima bee did have an atmosphere
at one point it would have been stripped
away by one of these violent outbursts
leaving Proxima be dangerously exposed
space an atmosphere dampens the
temperature gradients between light and
shadow
so in sunlight it is just burning hot
but right next door in a shadow it is
freezing cold
without an atmosphere Proxima B would be
a barren wasteland blasted by intense
radiation from its star completely
uninhabitable Proxima be perhaps best
shot at finding earth 2.0 so far is
actually dried-out husk of a world that
has lost its atmosphere maybe lost any
water that it also harbored simply by
being that close to its parent star
[Music]
próxima be maybe the nearest exoplanet
but it's not the only option the future
of humanity may lie in an incredible
star system just 40 light-years away
we've just found a really exciting
system where there's not just one chance
to have a new earth seven